i'm so tired of lying he's just your
friendly neighborhood spider-man but
what does it really take to do this role
intense contractual pressures forbidden
romances damaging injuries and going
undercover and that's just a taste of
what it's really like for the peter
parker actors
we've got the inside scoop on the real
spidey experience
we share something that only us three
could possibly imagine
going to high school as a regular teen
was never really in the books for tom
holland until he went undercover that is
i went to an american high school
undercover to see what it would be like
to be an american high schooler what
better way to perfect his new yorker
accent even the teachers didn't know
that i was
not a real student
work it work it work it all these
spideys got nimble and toned to play the
superhero toby bulked up like nobody's
business i worked out for five months
six days a week up to four hours a day i
had a nutritionist and i was eating four
to six meals a day lots of protein but
every spider-man has their own method
unfortunately they're not always that
into it
lifting weights is not for me
personally but i obviously have to do it
for this tom's training really started
years before he was ever even cast well
i was lucky that i did a show in london
um called billy elliot they trained me
in gymnastics while i was doing that
show when it came time to wear the
spidey suit though the actor took a less
conventional route you basically do like
a yoga class
while they electrocute you it's awful
it's a lot of fun and it works but it
really is the worst thing i've ever done
will every spider-man fall in love with
their mj or gwen stacy
after toby mcguire and kirsten dunst had
to work together post-breakup for the
second and third film in their franchise
amy pascal knew this was something that
could happen again down the line so she
had a chat with the spidermans and their
respective co-stars making sure to put
on the brakes to any potential dating
each other but love happens especially
when the chemistry is as electric as
it's been between these actors no
suggestions even from major producers
we're going to stop these romances
when you play spider-man right
there's only three people to have done
it on the big screen and it's quite an
alienating experience so how exactly
does it feel for these spider-men to
watch other actors wear the suit or to
meet the actor they're following up i'd
been a little bit worried about meeting
him because of what happened and i
didn't know if he was sensitive about
the subject luckily their meeting was a
good one i met andrew at the baftas and
he was so nice so sweet you know it
really felt like he was passing on the
torch andrew obviously talks the talk
and walks the walk the the young guy
playing it now tom holland is a
fantastic actor by the way tom's
encounter with the first spider-man
well he didn't see me and i was like
toby toby hi spider-man luckily they got
better acquainted soon enough no doubt
it's strange but in the end the role
does kind of connect them all in a very
special way i'm genuinely happy that
they chose another brit and i'm and i'm
not bitter okay this bro love fest is
beautiful we actually do have a whatsapp
grouch
and it breaks breaks breaks my heart
becoming spider-man was a literal dream
come true for andrew garfield i signed
up to serve the story and to serve this
incredible character that i've been
dressing up since i was three yeah but
dreams don't always turn out the way we
help got to work with incredible actors
a really great director and they were
really really trick i found i was very
young and while winning the role and
wearing the iconic suit meant a lot the
baggage that came with it wasn't so
great
i i learned a lot yeah about what feels
good and what doesn't feel good
[Music]
with great power comes great
responsibility even off screen here we
go three two
who did tom holland hang out with when
he wasn't working other superheroes of
course
this little boy has proven himself to be
a real life superhero holland got to
mentor the young hero in the making
making sure to cover all the most
important bases let me get your eyes
straight
yeah this crew is in solid company
superheroes all around
tom holland struggled with a leg injury
filming no way home one so bad that
everyone got a break while the peter
actor recovered toby maguire had his own
injury incident but the main difference
was that he faked his in an attempt to
get a better deal for the sequel luckily
even after the incident he got to keep
on with the role even if it meant having
to deal with self-referential jokes in
the movies both then and now
[Music]
i struggled to hold it all i kind of
rejected it a lot while fame comes with
its upsides and being recognized around
the world can be a total dream it's not
so great when you really just want to
lay low and have a no bones day i kind
of resisted it a lot i was young for
andrew the struggle was real it was the
attention which i struggled with to be
honest the visibility the being known
and not being able to walk around the
street tom really felt the pressure
himself amid intense press tours
ones that he couldn't say no to until
his body did for him that is
yeah our boy got himself off stage and
threw up at a panel it's a hefty price
to pay
he was the very first spider-man so
naturally it wasn't going to be an easy
deal it was a
a bit of a process but first we did like
an audition on videotape in a little
room but as if it was going to be that
simple
they saw the tape and they said well
we know he can act we want to see him do
an action scene okay okay this sounds
good good vibes i was in pretty good
shape so i i peeled the thing down and
tied it off of my waist and did the
fight scene topless with a screen test
this good it's no surprise they found
their peter parker in maguire
a few rounds of auditions and this
amazing screen test with emma stone
later andrew was locked in to playing
spider-man opposite an amazing gwen
stacy garfield himself was pretty
impressed with his scene partner too
come on oh my god
after there being so many impressive
actors taking on the role of spider-man
before what did it take for holland to
really impress how many auditions did
you have eight and these auditions yeah
not just a few pages for my auditions
for spider-man all i did was send them
videos of me doing backflips like after
a long journey and showing the team how
perfect he was for the part the actor
really made a splash when it counted
final audition and it was a fight scene
with chris evans and it said spider-man
flips in the frame
so obviously he backflipped in
persistence pays off
when is it time for a spider-man to move
on tom holland has already said he
doesn't want to get stuck in the role
and needs to explore other avenues of
his life andrew garfield dealt with his
own tough time when he came to terms
with the fact that he just wasn't loving
what he was doing with the franchise
anymore the actor didn't attend one gala
event for the second movie just needing
a knight to himself but that did not go
over well with the producers and
well since there wasn't a third film as
expected you can only imagine how the
team felt about that choice
[Music]
for his first leading role in homecoming
tom holland was about one and a half
million dollars richer that number
jumped to 4 million for the sequel
andrew garfield got half a million for
his first time in the suit and a million
for his second
expecting two million to come in for the
third film but as we know that plan
didn't really turn out now toby the fact
is
toby remains the highest paid spider-man
at 4 million for the first movie
17.5 million for the second and 15
million for the third plus an extra
percentage of earnings based on the
film's success now that was a good
payday
being spider-man is absolutely harder
than we would have imagined this has
been the most incredible experience this
whole journey from the day i got cast
that spidey suit is carried with those
actors even after they're no longer
playing the role because if we know
anything it's that it's never really too
late for them to put the mask back on